[Music]
no one welcome to this video this video
is about setups where Blake plays the
moves d5 and should 2g form often in the
majority of cases Blake will also
combine this with c6 and ESX and build
up this triangle pong symptom
yeah the setup is often employed by
players who regularly played the Slav
defense so if they have this in their
repertoire they will often go for a
setup like this it's somewhat related to
the Bishop f5 setups that we examine in
a separate chapter now before we go into
him and detail I want to show you what
our standard moves are because we have a
basic lay predefined move order that we
are going to play basically every time
unless like to something extraordinary
like taking on c4 where we need to react
or play some odd move order that we can
exploit so what I call the mainline in
this chapter is the following so we go 9
f3 and now black will play Bishop before
of course but the autumn is a little bit
can be a little bit different they can
play it here which is questionable or
they can prepare it with Knight f6 and
c6 and this is going to be probably the
most frequently seen order of moves so
we play Bishop g2 with a propitiatory
form and now an important moment for the
move autumn similarly to the Bishop f5
chapter where we would have almost the
same position but the bishop here
similar to this chapter I recommend to
start with the move c4 here instead of
castling so I suggest to play C for him
like will most of the time play 6 and
then you should play the move age of 3
this is what I ultimately came up with
after studying various other move order
options one incentive to play like this
is the simplicity and somewhat
similarity to the Bishop f5 approach in
the bishop FY 5 lines we also play
ceefor before castling one reason why
this is also a good idea here is that
after age three black might decide to
put it back to at five I know this
doesn't sound ultra logical but we will
see that putting it on H five does have
its problems as well so in such a
scenario we would basically play Knight
c3 and we would have the Bishop a5
chapter with white having an extra move
age three which does not hurt at all but
them opposition so this kind of move
order is going to be what we are doing
usually we play c4 before cancelling and
then Age 3 and the absolute the main
position of this chapter is here when
black has a choice between playing 90
bt7 and to Bishop 7 they could transpose
into one another but this is basically
what the main main line looks like we
have to first before we get to the main
line sort out some other move autumn
ideas mostly this is related to black
not playing Knight f6 early on but
delaying this move and it's not a huge
issue we basically play in the same
fashion as we do in the main line and
all fled were transpose but it's useful
to check off so we play 90 of three
and here the soundest way to go for
Bishop g4 setup is to play either c6 now
or Knight f6 the immediate move Bishop
reform is not a good choice because we
can exploit that immediately by going
Knight to e5 I need to emphasize that
you can play g3 but like you know it
doesn't make all that much sense in
comparison to 95 it's all good to have a
standard set of yeah moves that you can
play but if they play bad moves we
should exploit that 95 is just a very
useful tempo on the bishop now the
bishop has to move again and after
Bishop h5 we can immediately go for a
punishment by playing G form and H form
now this is not some loose expansion
this is just a good way of playing we
are simply trying to trap the bishop
with h5 leg is in some trouble him the
relatively best for him at this point
would be e six and now we should play
Bishop g2 the reason is that the
immediate age 5 after Bishop F or F 3 F
6 is not as convincing this is not bad
but I think Bishop g2 is a little bit
better
black really doesn't have a way to solve
this issue on the on the King side with
h5 still being a threat and after Bishop
d6 h5 Bishop before f3 we have a huge
advantage the only way for black to not
lose the full Bishop now is f6 after
which we now get to the only moment
where you need to know something in this
line or should remember something to be
a lot better and that is the move Knight
to f7 it's quite funny yeah we just jump
right in and just basically force the
black King to move so that it is on a
less safe position so like it will take
we take on e form and after D takes
Bishop takes we have a huge advantage
yeah like can play Bishop g3 but this is
just not going to do all that
we play King f1 and we have all the
moves coming for us now with camper 23
for example would attack here and here
and on top of that of course b7 is
currently attacked yeah this is a great
position for wide also King on g2 will
be safe and that is a really bad line
somewhat better in comparison after 95
is Bishop f5 this is also better for
white but not as much as bishop aged 5
so we play c4 and surprisingly putting
more pressure on the center and now
black will probably play f6 and drive
the knight back it's just such a
annoying piece you know so f6 we go back
they will probably play ECM 93 c6 that
is I think relatively best what black
can do and now I just recommend to play
or g3 which is according to our usual
way of playing in a Bishop f5 setup in
all of our setups and here black has the
really dreadful move f6 in which is of
course not helping at all and you could
in fact get this position with a pawn f7
if you put moves on the board starting
d4 d5 90 or 3 Bishop f5 so this is a
full extra tempo but it is just a bad
one and we have a very straight forward
planning what we should do is play
Bishop g2 Castle and then go for a form
may be prepared by 92 and rook e1 moves
like that if we get a fine we will
expose the weakness here of them is 6
pawn and the whole black position in
general so this all in all renders
Bishop g4 as goes to a mistake it's not
a good move and it is a lot better in
comparison for black to play Knight f6
or c6 we should start with c6 I have to
mention that this move is not met all
that frequently in fact because many
players who play the Slav would rather
play Knight f6 first be more flexible
for sidelines for example here after c6
black also has to be ready or a Bishop
f4 which is a London system with black
already committed to c6 that it's not
everybody's cup of tea most people
against in London wouldn't play c6
voluntarily this is by the way not a bad
alternative in particular here as black
as mentioned is committed to c6 so if
you just want to play something else
this is not a bad spot to do that now we
go to g3 YUM and this of course has no
drawback whatsoever I just want to
mention that c6 is not going to happen
all that frequently because of move all
the problems okay so g3 Bishop g4 him
they can play Knight f6 but that we will
look at why a knight f6 on move - so
Bishop G form Bishop g2 and 97 this
would be the way to somehow make use of
omitting that f6 so to prioritize
development of the Queen side one point
of this way of developing can be that
black is a bit quicker with controlling
the e5 square so that there's no Knight
e5 coming it's not really what we would
do against Knight f6 but still that
could be a motivation instead of 97 that
can also play a 6 first but they will
play Knight d7 on I have 6 soon and that
is also just a transposition so as I
mentioned we will play C form before
cancelling so c4 here is what we should
do and what we always have to check is
what happens after the capture on C form
I don't in my experience that doesn't
happen that often
black oftentimes just once the pawn
triangle and be solid they don't want to
grab material um but we have to know of
course what what would happen so if
black takes um I suggest a standard
procedure to to handle that and we
should play always 92 first so after 92
we are pretty much sure that we get the
pawn back so after 96
[Music]